hi there steve here steve kaufman
um you know i always forget to say if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
i notice other people say that
um
now today i want to talk about sort of
mastering or nailing down russian
grammar and this is kind of my next
challenge i just finished my uh 90-day
challenge in arabic and persian i put up
a couple of videos of
of my uh level which isn't very great
but it's kind of what i was able to
achieve doing two languages during that
90-day period granted i had been on
arabic before
most of my persian was during that uh
that three-month period
now
this month
month of may
second two weeks i'm going to be in
ukraine
uh and so therefore i say this is an
opportunity for me to work on my those
two slavic languages russian and
ukrainian
uh russian of course is spoken by far
more people than ukrainian
but i enjoy them both i think they're
both beautiful languages uh both
languages have behind them interesting
histories uh
you know
lots of people that i want to get to
know
uh
but the problem i have is while i have
good comprehension in both i've listened
to audiobooks and
and and read on history and literature
and you know current events
uh when i go to speak i always make the
same mistakes
and and the reason is very simple and
that is because
um we have habits so
my strongest language habit is english
so in english if you have say a noun
the book
whether you're from the book to the book
by the book
you know
any
thing that happens to the book it's
still book
whereas in russian or ukrainian or other
slavic languages it could be knight nigu
kanigi
and so it changes so i understand the
theory behind that but when i speak my
natural instinct is to just go knight
or book that it doesn't change so and
the same is true of some of the other
aspects of the slavic languages like the
verbs of motion
like the aspect of verbs which again i'm
not going to go into the details of
these things but these are things that
are habits
that slavic speakers have and which i as
an english speaker don't have and so how
do i then
develop these habits
and i because i'm going to be in
ukraine speak initially in eastern
ukraine and kiev where they mostly speak
russian and then in levi where they
speak
ukrainian
what i want to do is make a concerted
effort to improve not so much to expand
my vocabulary
but to improve in the nuts and bolts
when i first started into reading up on
language learning
somebody described language learning as
consisting of two strategies
one is the sort of
big picture learning and the other is
the nuts and bolts
and so big picture is lots of listening
and reading interesting content
eventually
acquiring more vocabulary
gaining familiarity with the language
but at some point you also have to work
on the nuts and bolts i have found from
experience that reading declension
tables reading explanations really
doesn't do much for me i don't retain
very much so i still struggle with my
accuracy and so what my strategy now is
to use our mini stories and i'm doing
that because i've had so much success in
learning greek and and persian and
arabic using the mini stories i feel
there are they are a very good way of
focusing in on the nuts and bolts
because what happens is you know the
story i know the stories i've done them
now in three four languages i know the
stories i've listened to them many many
times so i'm better able to focus in on
the nuts and bolts
uh i be i'm aware of different aspects
of the language every time i hear
the story or listen or read the story
plus
in link i can i can save phrases i'm
only for example i now in my russian and
ukrainian i only save phrases phrases
that embody these aspects of the
language that i want to get better at
then as i turn the page in my lesson i
review these
structures
and i only use the reverse flash card so
i see it in english i have to say it in
russian or ukrainian then
when i go to listen to the story again
i'm more aware of that structure and of
course in the many stories the same
structure repeats at least three at
least four times
the same well yeah at least four times
between the different point of view and
then the questions you're going to get
the same structure four times so with
this degree of focusing in on structure
not worrying so much about the meaning
which i know
i am hoping that this is going to
help me
develop new habits and at the end of the
month
from leve i will speak in ukrainian and
russian and you can judge whether my
control of the nuts and bolts has
improved now
you see there again
uh
um
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay there you have it and that's how
bad i am right now and come the end of
may i hope to be a lot better
thank you for listening and remember you
got to go big picture get it in you get
familiar with the language and you also
have to go
nuts and bolts at some point and if you
try to do the nuts and bolts up front
before you have the big picture it's too
difficult whereas once you have the big
picture you can focus in on the nuts and
bolts and i think the mini stories are a
great way to do that thank you for
listening bye for now
you